the winners of the 2021 nobel peace
prize have just been announced in oslo
the award was given to two journalists
maria ressa from the philippines and
dimitri muritov from russia the nobel
committee cited their efforts to
safeguard freedom of expression in their
respective countries ressa founded the
investigative journalism website rappler
and has focused much of her work on
philippine president rodrigo duterte's
controversial and violent war on drugs
muritov was one of the founders of
russia's independent newspaper navia
gazetta which has a fundamentally
critical attitude towards power the
committee said and has been its
editor-in-chief since 1995.
the norwegian nobel committee
has decided
to award the nobel peace prize for 2021
to
maria rissa
and dimitri muratov for their efforts
to safeguard freedom of expression
which is a precondition
for democracy and lasting
peace ms ressa and mr muratov
are receiving the peace prize
for their courageous fight
for freedom of expression in the
philippines
and in russia
speaking by telephone right after the
announcement maria said she was in shock
and explained what impact the prize will
have on her and her team
it means we keep doing what we do right
if this is added energy added focus i
mean the the biggest problem that we
have is that
so much happens in darkness and i think
what we've always tried to do is to
continue doing journalism accountability
journalism
investigations that will hold power to
account it's just become far more
difficult
with the advent of technology and social
media and the way social media has
allowed
budding authoritarians and dictators to
be to exploit their algorithms and
and take power and crumble democracies
from within so i mean thank you so much
for recognizing
what effort it takes to do the job of a
journalist today
well for more i'm joined in the studio
by dw's political correspondent simon
young simon thanks for coming in firstly
let's start with tell us a little bit
more about maria ressa and who she is
and rappler in particular yeah
the filipino journalist maria wrestler
she's
really been a leader of uh media
scrutiny of president duterte in
particular
and his regime she's
been in a sort of a battle with him
really maria ressa criticizes president
duterte as an authoritarian who's
undermined democracy
in that country and she says that the
country's become a dictatorship uh
disguised as a democracy so uh she's
been pursuing uh his career since uh
before he became president back in 2015
she interviewed duterte and
um it was in in that interview for
instance that he revealed that he
personally had had killed three people
and that's
been one of the hallmarks of his
campaign against uh drugs in the
philippines uh which she says has gone
way too far and as i say is undermining
democracy her platform this uh online
magazine rappler
is a special um
media product because it is run by women
and uh
it's been repeatedly in uh conflict with
the duterte regime there's been uh more
than a dozen uh prosecutions against uh
rappler and its journalists since 2017
and maria ressa herself was uh has been
prosecuted
over a text that appeared on that online
site it was an
expose of corruption by a senior judge
in the philippines so it just shows you
across a whole range of of levels and
different stories and for for many years
maria ressa has been sort of leading the
fight to bring uh the leaders of the of
of her country to account all right in a
moment we get across to russia and speak
further on dimitri muritov so i won't
ask you about him right now but what
message do you think the the nobel
academy are trying to send with these
awards that they've handed out today
well as was said in the citation what
they uh are intending to do is to
underscore the basic human rights uh two
in particular uh the freedom of
expression and the freedom of the media
and they say that their logic is that uh
those freedoms are essential to
preserving and promoting international
peace dialogue between nations and
within nations of course to bring
stability
uh and so they hope that by putting the
spotlight on these two leading uh
opponents it has to be said
media representatives who who stand up
to authoritarian regimes in the
philippines and in russia they hope that
to bolster uh not just the media in
those countries but i think in other
places around the world where conditions
are difficult for journalists indeed all
right simon young thank you very much
and we can speak now to emily show and
she's our correspondent in moscow emily
thanks for joining us tell us a bit more
about the newspaper novella gazetta and
it's editor in chief and nobel peace
prize winner dmitry muratov
well dmitry muratov is one of the
founding members of nova gazette and
he's actually been its editor in chief
as well for over 20 years
and i think an important figure in
standing up to
the government here
or rather criticizing it through
journalism and also standing up for
freedom of speech here in russia now
nova gazette itself is somewhat of an
institution in the country um it's a
newspaper that comes out three times a
week and they're really known for their
investigative journalism
including particularly into human rights
issues and also
corruption for example
it was one of the newspapers one of the
media outlets that revealed the presence
of russian soldiers in eastern ukraine
during the war there
and also the newspaper that revealed the
fact that gay people in chechnya in the
russian region of chechnya were being
tortured for their sexuality murataf and
the other journalists at nova gazetta
have been really uncompromising over the
years in upholding their values
and continuing their investigative work
despite the increasing difficulties
they've received a lot of threats over
the years one journalist that i spoke to
in my reporting there about the
newspaper
told me that it sometimes feels like
they're working in a war zone or you
know walking over a minefield because
actually six of the journalists from
that newspaper have been killed over the
years for their work including the
well-known investigative journalist
annapolitovsky
actually it was the 15th anniversary of
her murder yesterday
and we went to speak to some of her
colleagues at the newspaper
let's take a look at our report
journalist yelina kastuchinko is having
a first look at what used to be the
office of anna paletkovskaya her
colleague shown here in archive footage
now it's a museum in her honor
kastuchinka says palitkovskaya's
in-depth reporting about the wars in
chechnya was the reason she came to work
at the paper novea gazetta as an intern
at the time anna palitkovskaya was still
alive
she wrote about topics that no one else
wrote about because they were too scared
and she wrote in a way that meant it was
impossible to remain indifferent
her words hit you right in your soul and
they stayed there
is an investigative journalist herself
she often writes about controversial
social and political topics like lgbtq
rights and the presence of russian
soldiers in eastern ukraine she says
palitkovskaya is her role model even now
i constantly keep her in my head as an
example while i'm writing all the time
of course i can hardly hope that i'll
grow to her level that's impossible but
it's as if she lights my way
novaya gazetta is one of the few
remaining critical media outlets in
russia over the years six of the
newspapers journalists were killed for
their work including anapalikovskaya
many in the team still remember her huge
dedication
once she came into the canteen while we
were having lunch and started saying the
chechens are torturing people and
everyone just said wait a minute let's
have some lunch first she was always
thinking about her work
there were always lines of people
outside her office people who had come
from the caucasus from chechnya to ask
for her help
we can't ever betray our journalistic
standards because that would also mean
betraying the people who gave their life
for honest journalism we here continue
their work
was renowned for her reporting about
russia's wars in chechnya and her fierce
criticism of the kremlin's policies
on october 7 2006 she was shot four
times at her moscow apartment
those who carried out the killing were
later sentenced in court but those who
ordered it were never held accountable
15 years after the murder of
annapolitkowska pressure on independent
journalists here in russia has been
rising in recent months media outlets
and journalists critical of the kremlin
have faced police searches and criminal
cases and many have been declared
foreign agents
the foreign agent label shows that the
russian government sees journalists as
enemies elena kastuccinca feels the
reporter says she regularly receives
threats for her work but to her anna
palitkovskaya's example shows that
journalists must carry on even in the
face of intimidation oluje
people who kill journalists or think
about it cannot be allowed to be given
the illusion that their actions will
stop a certain topic being covered that
it could get them off the hook it won't
when a journalist is killed that
person's colleagues must step up and
take their place
office will remain empty but her
fearlessness continues to inspire those
who refuse to be silent
inspiring those that refuse to be silent
indeed and that's obviously what this
award today was trying to uh say but the
award is ju is about more than just one
newspaper emily it's also about freedom
of press in russia as a whole which has
come under severe threat in recent years
tell us more
well i would say that nova gazette is
becoming
you know a real rarity
now on the media landscape in russia
there's been increasing pressure on
independent journalists you know over
the last few years but i would say this
last year in particular the pressure has
really been upped
we've seen a whole list of media outlets
um that are critical of the kremlin
being declared uh to be so-called
foreign agents which means that they
face you know not only the stigma that
comes with that label but also a huge
administrative burden which can you know
have mean problems with financing and so
on some media outlets have even had to
close and also individual journalists
have been declared uh foreign agents as
well some of the people that i spoke to
about that have told me that it really
makes them feel like they are enemies in
their own country and even in recent
months there's been a hashtag that's
been trending
which is journalism is not a crime
several independent journalists have had
to leave the country there have been
criminal cases against them police
searches and so on so i think this is a
really important signal right now for
journalists um here in russia
to keep doing uh what they are doing you
know from the international community
indeed an important signal all right
emily thank you very much dw's emily
shown in moscow